it's it just introduces a little bit of
variety because as we've said before you
know we need variety if the brain is
always doing the same thing the brain
loses interest so the it's kind of
almost like
contradictory the brain needs repetition
but if it gets too much repetition it
loses interest the brain also requires
novelty variety
[Music]
hi shelby hi steve
how are you so come on
mercy
okay
so we're going to talk about vocabulary
and reviewing our vocabulary
because
let me just first chat a bit about
vocabulary because it's something that
comes up all the time how do we review
vocabulary
first of all people say you know how can
you talk about listening and reading
when you know nothing you know so
obviously that comes up all the time how
can i listen and read i don't know
anything that's true so at the beginning
you know nothing so
no matter what you use it's not
comprehensible input that's why you get
on link and you look words up and you
look words up and they go into your
database and so you now have these words
starting to accumulate in your database
you've looked them up for the meaning it
doesn't mean you know them it just means
that you've met them before and when
you've met them before they're no longer
blue they're yellow and it just as if by
magic by continuing to listen and read
and occasionally review
your words or phrases
the language starts to stick so so
that's the first issue yes at first you
know nothing and slowly the brain starts
to get used to the language
then the second issue is you know
what about all these flash cards like
how often should i flash guard how do i
flash card how do i review the words
how much time do i spend reviewing
versus reading
you know this kind of stuff comes up all
the time
yeah my view is it depends on what you
like to do okay i haven't seen any proof
that you know religious you know
[Music]
whatever they call it uh you know spaced
repetition
there are people who swear by it but i
don't use it
uh i think it's largely a matter of what
you like to do
and i to me i can only talk about what i
like to do to me reviewing the words or
phrases that i've saved
is just another form of exposure to the
language
it's another form of input i don't like
to rack my brain trying to remember
things i like to see
a list or
flashcards i just have all the
information on the front of the
flashcard it's it just introduces a
little bit of variety because as we've
said before you know we need variety if
the brain is always doing the same thing
the brain loses interest so the it's
kind of almost like
contradictory the brain needs repetition
but if it gets too much repetition it
loses interest the brain also requires
novelty variety so before link if i
studied a language i would buy three
starter books i would buy teach yourself
colloquial living language whatever
cover the same beginner material in
three different books
so in a way it's all the early beginner
stuff but in fact it's three different
books so you introduce variety
so when you are reading a text and
you've got your links in yellow and
stuff you are in fact reviewing your
links however reviewing them in another
format is a introduces a variety like a
different way
of reviewing those words
um
so and and i when we go to
sharing your screen i'll show you some
of the things that i do but let me first
ask you
to what extent have you been using the
flashcards yeah great question i've been
experimenting
so um i'm trying to use link on my phone
more i tend to use it on my computer for
pretty much everything except for um
you know like reading a new lesson for
the first time
um or i'm sorry in reverse i i mean
that's what i mainly use my computer for
and then you know reviewing like just
reading i like to read a lot on my
computer and then like import a new
youtube video or something i usually
start from my computer and then i listen
to
the playlist on my phone so i'm trying
now to do like my daily links review on
my phone exclusively
and um
yeah i have a lot of links right now
because i cannot get enough of i mean
i'm certainly introducing new content
probably a little bit faster than what
is recommendable so i have a really
really long list and i'm thinking now i
should probably start using the tags
more um i don't tend to categorize why i
mean the tags will appear on my words
automatically for the most part and i
don't usually edit those very much so i
think i want to do that to organize them
because i just have such a long list um
but when i'm in a new lesson like the
mini stories when i read a new one
i'll tend to do
what i think you recommended once which
is to just hit the review button as i
page and i'm liking that because
like with what you're saying you know
that you you need the repetition and the
novelty i think it's the same concept uh
with why you like to shuffle the
playlist you know because if you
if you if you get used to the pattern
and seeing something only in this
specific context or in this specific
order
the brain gets desensitized to that
right and it's like remembering the
pattern rather than actually
you know the meaning of each word that's
how i'm perceiving it for me so that's
why i'm trying to mix up different ways
of doing my vocab review but i have so
many links that i i can't possibly
review them all so maybe i should slow
down a little bit
well i don't think you should like i
think it depends on what people like to
do if you are enjoying the content that
you're bringing in i am you're in the
zone yeah why would you worry about it
it is fun
i have in arabic i've got i don't know
40 000 say wow i know i know very few of
them
it doesn't bother me i don't spend a lot
of time reviewing them because again you
have only so much time to spend
so i think you as long as you're
spending time with the language
listening reading
reviewing whatever you're doing you're
spending time with the language if
you're doing it enjoyably and if you
enjoy what you're doing
that's good and i don't think there's
any advantage in saying gee i think i
should review all my links because your
brain will go numb after about 15
minutes of trying to review all these
links you've seen that's been right yeah
i spent about an hour the other night
reviewing
maybe like the first
like abc
the wedding's abc the other night
is i mean it's it's okay to do but and
then you'll stop at c and then when you
go back in you know started it again
because it's hard to find where you were
the last time and it's there's nothing
wrong with doing it but i think you're
kidding yourself if you're if you think
you're stalking those things into memory
and even with the spaced repetition
system uh you know i think no matter
what you what you learn you're gonna
you're gonna forget it if you don't see
it again in context whatever so i don't
worry about nailing things down but
let's have a look why don't we share
your screen and and have a look at the
different things that are and
unfortunately we're only going to be
sharing the computer way of using this
and it works a little different on the
mobile apps
and maybe uh sometimes we can connect uh
an ipad or something or an iphone and
and look at it on the app but for today
we're just gonna share your screen on
your computer and i'll show you some of
the things that i do in reviewing my
vocab oh awesome looking forward to it
let's do it
okay
okay
now
um
i see that that's great like you're into
all kinds of different things that's
good like motivation is so key
motivation variety
i and for you of course
like french is not totally foreign
because you have english and you have
spanish
for me in arabic i have and turkish and
persian i have to spell greek even i
spend a lot of time on the many stories
because it's just hopelessly difficult
for me to go into into something
different
and there isn't the same variety of
stuff out there so
you know people shouldn't get second
guess themselves if you're motivated to
to go after this great variety of
content that's what you should do it's
the whole idea is to have fun with the
language if you're positive like i have
a positive attitude and you enjoy what
you're doing you will learn it's that
simple so you can open if you don't have
to do the many searches if you don't
want you can open up whatever you want
here i want to show you
sort of some issues around reviewing
vocabulary
okay so we'll go to a lesson so yeah i
was checking out some music videos and
like reading wikipedia pages of the
artist
i just get so curious about who these
people are
so let's see
let's hop into this one
and then are we gonna want the audio too
uh
well we can but it doesn't really matter
i mean we can hear the text
it's
we'll see let's wait
uh pick anyone it doesn't matter
a lot of links in this one
okay
so
i'm just going to move this
so
right now you have 51 save you can see
if you move your cursor up to the top
right hand corner there
you have 51 saved links right now
but let's go down to the bottom of the
page the right hand corner and of course
the first thing and which i do at an
early stage in any languages i'll review
the individual links from that page so
if you click on that arrow
we go straight into flashcards
and it'll flash card all of the words or
phrases in that lesson
and you'll have to go through them all
so however many they are there are
that's how many you're going to have to
go through
right yeah and this page is is great too
i don't know how familiar people are but
you can customize this as well so
there's
it's quite customizable i recommend
people check it out well we could show
them that go up to the settings
yeah so i'm gonna move this again
the except it's set on the reader
settings here but i can go into review
settings and then if there are certain
types of flash cards that people like
more than others or like don't want to
see
one or a few of them then you can
uncheck them here and cards per session
right yeah so i haven't changed this i
think it's i mean i think it's pretty
good idea to get
as much variety as possible but there
might be one or
a couple that people don't like
and then
we can mess with all of this
so i i put the translation on the front
of them i see them i can't remember it
doesn't matter what you do it's just
exposure
so you can experiment with different
different approaches
uh and the cards per session offline 10
is uh but if you're only doing the
words or phrases on a particular lesson
page probably won't be many more than 10
in most cases
right that's very true yeah
um and then this page also has really
great just like everything with link
great keyboard shortcuts too so i can do
all of this on my keyboard i'm just
gonna hit enter
you know
move through it
okay
should i keep going no so that's so you
can go through them all there so now
let's go back to the lesson page
click x we're on the lesson page now so
i will not normally do that especially
if i it's early in a language now the
next thing i i see for so so the other
thing you can do
is if you go
click on lessons at the top
there
and that'll take you to the vocabulary
to the
now you can go to vocabulary
[Music]
so now you got all your vocabulary which
as you say is a lot right
yeah
so
if you go
to
you know you can search for different
things so starts with if you click on
start screen
so you can look for a word that begins
with something ends with something
contains something
a phrase containing a word
or a translation or whatever so you can
search for different things okay
we need to do that but i mean like for
example if you say starts with let's say
uh starts with en that's going to pull
up a lot right
most likely
yeah okay okay you got lots
so so that's one thing you can do
now
now let's get rid of that or it'll limit
our next search
so if we go
to
more actions
no
uh
more actions what can we do there let's
click on more actions what can we do
with more actions
so we can change the status we can do
all kinds of stuff there export as an
anki file
right
and so you can check the boxes here so
right
usually you would do that before more
actions
if you go to filters click on filters
so you can now search based on
your tags
uh you can
no but you could you don't have that
many tags but you could like whatever uh
you could search for like if you had the
subjunctive or whatever
uh you can also search for
just your
known words or just your new words or
whatever right
you can also if you look at course you
can
look for only the words from a given
course so french french link who is she
or link many stories or whatever
or just a particular lesson
all right so
and so you can do that so then you get
the lesson part 10. so now you've got
the vocabulary from that and you can
review it
so you know you're saying you got you
know
thousands and thousands of words but if
you wanted to focus in on a particular
lesson and again it gives you
it gives you a variety of things that
you can do again the you know we talked
about the importance of variety so you
can go at your vocabulary in different
ways because if you're just going
through a list eventually the brain just
goes numb
yeah yeah it's like it's trying to do
you know it's like when you you're doing
flash cards or lists you're basically
asking your brain to do something
different you know you're saying hey
remember this right one isolated word
and your brain will start to do that
but
then i'm within with
it's it's like these comprehensive
questions trying to remember what
happened in the story all the brain
really wants is exposure to the language
it doesn't want to be challenged or
asked to remember stuff in my experience
now teachers might say something
different
now let's go back to my lessons
so and and pick a lesson doesn't matter
number 30 is fine all i want to sort of
cover here is that that that
vocabulary review is another activity
that you can do that introduces variety
it's another way of exposing yourself to
the language so if we look at where it
says review links 51 at the top right
hand corner
we click on that
so it said we can go through all of
those in flashcards if we want
or click on where it says view all links
on the left hand side
so here you have a list of all these
words the 51 words
that
so far you've saved in this course
and you could go through if you if you
click on any one of them you'll hear it
and you'll see you know the card opens
up right
yeah this is awesome okay now but what i
like to so that's one way of doing it so
you don't see
you don't see and of course you can
export it to anki there if you want but
if you go to manage go to the top
it says manage
so here you get them and i don't mind i
like doing this actually i like seeing
everything in front of me so it's a
quick review so you now have this list
of all those 51 verbs words
and you can also if you want first of
all it's a great place to update you
know the status of words you can see
them very quickly if you click on them
you'll hear it in text-to-speech
uh you can search for you know you can
use your tags here if you want
but it's focused in on just the 51 words
and phrases that you have saved in this
lesson so
that's just another way to access your
vocabulary
uh
in other words
you can go to the vocabulary page or you
can find the vocabulary from this course
through that uh process in other words
going to the you know if we go back if
you go back on this just to remind
people how we got here
and one back one more
so we went to review links at the top
uh that opened up we said we don't want
to go through flashcards today because
it takes too long we'll view all links
and then we can
either look at them there or manage them
so
we're not good
yeah so uh i think we're gonna stop it
there we unfortunately we didn't have a
chance to walk through one of your
lessons and speak in french
but i just thought it was useful because
we often get questions about how to
review vocabulary and how much time to
spend there
and i think it's important to have fun
with it to do it when you feel like it
to not feel any obligation to do it
we don't know what at least i don't know
what causes words to stick
so you just do a variety of things if
you keep enjoying the language and enjoy
what you're doing the vocabulary is
going to stick yeah absolutely so you
want to read read more you want to do
review vocabulary do it do whatever
keeps you involved with the language
yeah i couldn't agree more yeah even
though i i have maybe more links than
some people might compared to how many
known words i have i'm really enjoying
learning and i'm feeling like i'm
understanding more and more and
especially with fringe i think it's it's
sometimes a more tough one to to
understand it when it's spoken by native
speakers so
so yeah even though i
you know might not be hitting all my
stats i'm definitely enjoying it and
that's more than i can say for any other
platform that i've used too you know i
eventually get bored with things and
fall off because it's hard i mean
enjoyment is the key and i think you're
going at it exactly how i do i'm if we
compare notes in terms of saved links
versus known words and say arabic for me
french for you probably would be quite
similar because we're just we're just
attacking all this content and we got
all these saved links and we don't even
worry about them we just throw them
somewhere
and they'll come back they'll come back
yeah think of how kids learn that's what
we're doing
exactly okay well we didn't speak much
french maybe next time we'll speak
french
allah
[Music]
you